welcome back to pj chain design today we
are going to talk about how to make this
lotus leaf and with the b setting on the
top as a pendant
are you ready let's get started
we're going to start at the top view and
you can draw any
of the lead shape either trace from
online or you can do your own design and
you can use the
curve command i was using the control
point
curve to draw this leaf
and after you draw that let's go ahead
to rebuild this guy
because we want a control point to be
more even in this case
i'm going to rebuild them into the 32
point
make sure that degree is equal 3 and
then let's click ok
so now we have this over there if you're
not drawing right in the center you can
simply just bring back the center but i
also like to have a
center of this area is the center of the
construction plane
so we need to find a center first let's
go to the
analyze and under the mass property then
you have the area
centroid and then you can click on this
closed curve hit enter and you will have
a dot
over there now notice that the dot
is the center of this area and the
gumball
sometimes it's not necessary is the
center of this area so we're going to
use this dot
as a reference point so i'm going to
select both the
dot and the curve and we're going to use
the move
tool and we want to snapping into this
point
and then type zero hit enter then we'll
have something like that
so the leave is a little bit wavy
so i'm going to do is to pick up the
point
and every other point or if you don't
like it to be
so regular you can pick every other two
or you can pick
maybe like jumping a little bit here
there
um so it's not so regular
or something like this maybe i want to
move this out and maybe just one point
over there
okay so with all this point there i'm
simply just going to move it up
so now you see my curve not only is the
irregular shape on the top view on the
side view you can see them
as up and down and after that you can do
it even more like this one need to go
higher this one want to go higher
this one want to go lower the next
things i wanted to do
is to creating a cross section and this
cross section is going to be
something like this i'm going to
starting from
this point and have them going up
and into a shape that you like
so for example something like this and i
want to snapping into
the quadrant here on the top on the
perspective and as you can see my curves
become like
this if you feel like this is too
bump you can kind of lower it down
maybe you want to move this one in a
little bit
and lower it down a little bit or
something like that so this will be
our profile to use to creating the
surface and if you don't want them to
coming into the point
you could lower down this one to be
something like this
so then they don't caving as a point so
let me show you what i'm planning to do
i'm picking on the surface and i have
the rail revolve
so this one is the profile this one's
the rail
and i have this one and holding my
shift click it over here then i will
have
this surface as you notice that going
into the really pointed and you can set
a stone right here right in the middle
if you want to to cover that or you can
keep
adjusting this curve maybe that is too
dramatic coming up maybe i want
something go like this way
and it will be smoother this time let's
record a history so we can see the real
time changing
let's go with the rail revolve
cross section and this is the rail and
this
is the axis and that's don't forget to
record history
and we'll get something like this right
so now right at this point
i could bring this point lower
or higher or
bring this point more toward this way
and that will relax to the center
it's really up to you for what you like
to do uh to create a thickness
if you want them to be over of the same
thickness you can just bring down
making a copy for whatever how thick you
want
and for this edges we can use the
blend surface and we can blend the
surface
and make sure the chain edge is equal
yes and one blend in between here
and here and let's hit enter then we'll
have something like
this and let's take a look on the render
view and see if that is what you like
the second thing is we need to have some
curve in order to flow the
diamond on it so i'm gonna coming into
the top view
and i'm going to extract the iso curve
and i want to extract depends on where
you want your stone to be
this is not the right direction so
coming to here you got toggle
then you can say i may want to have one
over here
one over here
not so symmetrical so one over here
and maybe another one
there and there so have five of them i'm
going to turn them into
the red color so it's easier for you to
see
so now i have one of the stone right
here and you can download a stone at a
link at the description below and what i
wanted to do
is to so what i like to do is make sure
this is the right size for my design
here maybe you want it to be bigger or
smaller you want to adjust it first
and after that we need to decide where
do we want to have the prong
and i'm going to simply just draw a
straight line
starting from this point roughly right
here
and coming into my front view and i want
to draw a straight line and moving this
one
up right there we are going to use the
pipe and if it is too long just one
de-scale it down
and something like that and let's pipe
it first
and see how that look i'm going to pipe
it
like about this size
and that will be one prong
let me move this on the size easier for
you to see
right so with this prong i'm going to
mirror to the other side
so then we have two prong if i have this
stone
and it's going to be mirror
to this side and notice that the stone
is actually touching each other so i
actually need to move this guy
out a little bit
something like this and let me mirror it
one more time to see if that working
really well so this is what we wanted to
have
when we arrange the stone have a gap a
little bit here is about 0.1
millimeter and i can delete this one and
i actually
it's going to use this as a set so let's
group it first
let's make a copy to our
first rail and i'm going to tilt it a
little bit
for something like this we'll follow
this curve over there
and we want to position into the right
place
so i'm going to move this one down and
of course i want to tilt it to
follow the curve that we have there and
tilt it
a little bit like this so the first one
need to follow
um the angle correctly and let's give it
a try
we want to do array a long curve and
this is the
object we want to array and this is the
curve
and i wanted to guess how many i needed
as you can see now it's number two
so we gotta have first one the very last
let's try maybe
10 and see how that works as you can see
it's not touching at all so i definitely
need more than that let's try 18 and
that's way too many as you can see is
overlapping so i'm let's try 14
all right 14 seems all right the stone
is a little bit close and you can try
13 and see if that is better and you can
also see there are
some uh the prong may not touching it
seems like a bigger gap right there
and it's tighter there and that is
normal so also the stone is not touching
and you also see some of the uneven
surfaces cutting on top of the stone
right so we actually need to make a
stone color
and i'm going to go back with this one
here how do we make stone color
is we're gonna coming over here i'm
going to draw a straight line
it's gonna go something like this just a
little bit smaller than the stone
and we want to create something like
this
and create a straight line much longer
like this
and with this line on the top view right
now it is
not aligned with our stone so i'm
actually going to pick up both of them
and then we are going to do a line
center horizontal center
and just move it here there now we have
that curve there
i'm going to creating the surface by
revolving
this curve using the vertex as a center
do 360 degree and it will get something
like this
so now you can see this surface right
there on my perspective
we need to make sure it's a solid so
we're gonna do
the cap command so now it is solid
and i accidentally to moving my prong
that's okay we're just going to move it
back
like this
and have that one to mirror to the other
side
okay so when we flow we need to flow all
of them together so let's group them
and again that's making a copy to this
place
first of all tilted them in this way
and second of all make sure that it is
sitting on the surface
and you can tilted them
in this way coming over here
and in the perspective you want to see
if the stone is in right angle look like
we need to tilt it
this way a little bit and maybe a little
bit more
and next we want to use an array along
the curve
all four parts are the object we want to
array
hit enter this is the curve and we have
the same with 13
and make sure this all stick it out so
we can cut it off and we actually don't
need
this one is over so i'm going to delete
this one
and did it this maybe in the middle i
want to set a stone so let me go ahead
and delete those
all right so we can have a stone right
in the center
and then let's do the bowling difference
this piece will be different uh with all
the color
on the bottom
so we'll have something like this let's
take a look on the render and see if
that look okay
so i'm going to repeating to finish the
rest of it
and i'm going to fast forward on that
[Music]
so now we have all of this and arrange
into the way that you like it we're
gonna do the bowling difference
to boiling out all the cutter you may
not want to do all of them at once if
your
computer is too slow
and the reason you want to cut it off on
the bottom is because the stone will
look brighter
and it will be easier to clean as well
so at the end i just want to have
another stone right there so i'm going
to
steal that one put it right in the
center and make them a little bit bigger
and because i have a prong there so that
should able to hold it
just need to move it down right there
and i might want to have
just a cylinder to cut it out
in the middle you can make the cylinder
about like this so i have a hole in
behind the stone
like this one will be trim it off or
boiling difference from that
all right let's take a look on the
render view
alright so you look okay and if you like
it you can just go ahead to
bowling it and for the rendering purpose
i would like to
rotate in 90 degree it will break all
the history that's okay
we're not gonna changing anything and i
want to have a jump ring so
um in the back and we can
basically just pipe in this one to be
something it doesn't have to be too big
something like this
all right and i can move this one close
to here
take a look on the perspective all right
so we can have a jump ring there
we'll have a chance to go through it uh
for this pendant
i hope you liked the video there will be
a lot more trick and tips on my
membership program
just click the join button on the right
button of the video
and hope to see you in the membership
program thank you for watching and see
you next
[Music]
you